un cellulare gigante oggi a grandissima
richiesta nuove resterai ski promo
dobbiamo scappare dalla scuola ma epica
i rivetti tipico di preti pop corn e
come sempre lasciate un mi piace qua
sotto
soprattutto se volete vedere vita e
vitale care serre e alla fine del video
potrete scriversi che voto date a queste
skyroom naufraghi assistiti e pronti per
i comuni principi cord se non mi seguite
senza così qua abbiamo la divisa
scolastica anche se non so perché tu hai
comunque la maglietta avrà scritto
scappa dalla cole che sulla lavagna e
qui ban ki moon che ha proseguito lo so
io sono max ti aiuterò a uscire fu c'è
scritto attento c'è la lava quindi stai
attento quindi anche in questa scuola il
paio con quella trattata la prima morte
di imitare e chi è che ha voglia di
contare quante volte muore di salea
eccoti pensavo che vado lì e corposo e
distrutto noi non ci credo vitale mi ha
superato
manca solo uno
e ieri perché facile lo scheletro
lamentiamo ma salviamo qua in quasi
mezzo non è la fama il pavimento attento
piano piano sta sciolto e proprio
proprio chimico no vabbè avete visto qua
il pavimento invece di ucciderti subito
ti rimpicciolisce
sarebbe bello se sono i plugin cui vieni
rimpicciolito è stato ha bisogno di
andare piano piano piano piano è bastato
mente ci sono poche persone siano dalla
barra vedo che si sono un po di persone
però sono rimasti indietro io li odio
questi sono sempre qua dai sono stati
sono facilissimi che questi mi sembrano
più facili ei nomi chiudere la porta in
faccia o una lezione d'arte non è mai
stata così caotica cerca di riuscire ad
arrivare alla porta la in alto
wow che bello c'è una matita gigante a
metà una gomma un'altra matita ma adoro
queste cose giganti peperino è già
arrivato io sono già dalla porta da
ingegno del saldo sul pennello
abbastanza facile queste skyroom
stranamente si può prendere una bibita
io no non lava prendiamo che no vabbè
c'è scritto qua che per aprire questa
cassaforte su youtube nel canale di
questa persona è trovare il codice nei
suoi video che in realtà che tra la mala
come foto
finalmente un mako di codici il codice
1437 quindi se volete parlava voi senza
impazzire a cercarla 14 37
ma bravo ma cosa dobbiamo fare
non so perché siamo chiusi chiusi qua
dentro aiuto proprio il peggio non ci
credo non entrate qua a meno che non
vogliate prendere e collezionare tutti i
brand giapponese prende questo beh
sappiate che poi rimanere incastrati
così almeno andate con un amico che
rimane fuori
ok è così come abbiamo rifatto tutto
daccapo allora se fa tedeschi prum non
entrate qua dentro
entrato in questo porta quali gustavo
tipo della cuginetta della scuola xvi
letto le porte sono chiuse ti devi
nascondere da qualche parte prima che
arrivi l'insegnante ci trova nei guai
una scusa frigo riguarda non ci credo si
sa che tutto nasca dg nel frigo mentre
l'insegnante è in pausa solo tipo i
cubetti di ghiaccio
anzi troppo frigo e ci sono delle scale
su questo cartone del latte che italiana
è salvato bisogna sensi della sera
potremmo avere un frigo la coca cola
attento a non cadere giù aiuto c'è un
pezzo di formaggio qui no tale caduto
dal formaggio ha sentito un rumore
strano
secondo tipo tutti e berlino che sa
strano chiama dei suoi giocattoli in una
torta questo è il paradiso orbita non so
come sono arrivato perché vi sono
rimarrà magenta linosa lì c'era un
passaggio segreto non è il paradiso per
te dentro un frigo zigana da masticare
burro di noccioline dall 1 di rosolina
quasi una mammina 9 un biscotto tipo
guarda sembra un gelato bellissimo
classica ante così il che è tutto la
maionese questo noto che cos'è poi passò
la torta
ehi ma tu stai già sulla gomma da
masticare wacom è davvero figo esterhazy
vino in frigo cosa fare queste cose
verdi non lo so forse un po ab ufficio
dove vitale ai quali dai potevo farcela
ma piano piano fiscale troppo distratto
da tutto ci siamo quasi
sono qua vicino a te
hai fatto ci sono ma non capisco se qual
caso o posso andare lì forse il vetro si
il m a ecco cos'era quella cosa perde
solo da loro marci
eccole cercato né delle uova salento
quasi solo delle uova marce sicuramente
meglio non cadere lì sopra perché
vorrebbero una mente ce l'ho fatta non
ci passa molto bisogna saltare sul
trovai vediamo evitare come vediamo un
po
vabbè io vado veloce lungo vediamo
quest'altro azione in questo credo se
qualcosa di elettrico nel frigo mia
freezzato ha quindi una scopa stare
quasi passare sopra al comporto come
succhiato l'uomo secolare comparto
no io perché non riuscito a scappare dal
frigo misero sono della scuola è bravo è
arrivato evitare allora andiamo per qua
vediamo marciano camera stai attenta si
sta riprendendo l'insegnante allora dice
che quasi un precipizio un buco molto
grande e quindi dobbiamo saltare ce la
possiamo fare per per andiamo suddiviso
ok sono diventato afferato vitale
direttamente va esaltato si guardasse
evitare ha la mia stessa di vita la
cravatta sapessi come la maglietta sopra
sembra fatto apposta
uno scritto di stare attenti alla povera
gigante ma batte alle mele perché questa
è una scuola passa dall affare gigante
delle mani giganti in una scuola sta
attento a non essere spiati kato aiuto
io vorrei dirvi tar le dove vittorio
sono fatti è bravo ce la fai tu dai no
ha fatto prendere anche me non avrei mai
pensato che in questa scuola dovevamo
evitare nuove reti di gomez che anche
nei paesi tanto ma tanto meno in arrivo
vitale ancora vivo qui sotto dai basta
allora manca poco
no mi ha preso lamela difficilissima
questa parte ok è salvato allora nel
frattempo godiamoci lo spettacolo
l'acqua non si possono applicare nelle
papparella nelle mele quindi noi
godiamoci lo spettacolo vitale non ha
preso
certo non terreno ma per hellen arrivati
a questa volta non mi fregano la
paperella sceglierai dai forse si sono
posti sono solo sogno anch'io con lo
scotto wow un percorso a ostacoli
postiamo nella palestra credo perché
quei cut di legno in generale balestre
quei cosi per applicarsi attento che
anche qua il pavimento e lava
e così sono tipo quelli per saltare tipo
di ginnastica artistica forse non lo so
non sono sicura terzino mi sono salvata
allora qui c bisogna arrampicarsi forse
è bellissima questa palestra e un po
mortale però salviamo bene quali sono i
saluti da fare no vabbè si è fatta si
farebbe vitale riuscito a superarmi
sopra stato per casello è quello di
rischiato di sparire la sopra per chi è
molto difficili questi aiuto devo farle
uscire dalla palestra se lo abbiamo
quasi fatto
poi c'è scritto che uno di questi
lockerz a un passaggio segreto che
esploriamo lì tutti guarda cosa mi un
colore diverso siamo siamo dentro locker
come si dice in italiano non mi ricordo
un armadietto e ci sono delle gomme da
masticare quindi dentro che stampa di
iniziative come la plastica re una
ciambella
un righello loro queste cose giganti ma
siamo noi che siamo più piccoli per
essere anche se sono dei libri quanto è
figo lo stecchino di un lecca lecca
tamente in queste stecchini superato
quasi una matita dove salì su una matita
gigante che bello l'abbraccio nei tre
cosette salviamo un cellulare gigante
nuovo bellissimo vedeva salire sulle
freccette queste di fini è super
difficile non ci credo che tyson
riuscito primo punto si sono così brava
titolo di un altro adesso deve salire
sui nascesse c'è anche un tuo magliette
appena tutto e per questo sono gravi
questi laser show da magliette che ci
sono quadri e c'è scritto tu vai per
primo ok ma aiuto sono caduta siamo nel
pavimento tipo 6
non lo so sono qui sul pavimento non
capisco non ti peugeot aspetta che salta
una vita ne è rimasto intrappolato a
caso in un varco spazio temporale tipo
in una stanza tutta bianca anche visivo
bacato il gioco però mi aspetto certo
che mi dispiace di robles è che non puoi
riprendere
questa volta però che non muori però lui
è bloccato lupa quindi vabbè continuo io
vediamo se si sblocca allora ladisa
siamo tornati batte di scienze diamo un
atto scritto sembra che ci sia stato un
esperimento scientifico che è andato
male ha creato questo buco nero è per
quello che io sono rimasto bloccato
latenza allora saltare sui banchi
l'attenzione libri saltato sulla sedia
mi sono fatto un po di paura aiuto
pacchetto è continuo ricorso aiuto è
altissimo più bravo guardi segna andare
piano piano viene costantemente di
questi accordi queste sono difficili io
non so lo avrei fatto a salvarci tutti
questi sarebbe morta altri 25 volte mi
sa che deve sostare su quelle mi
aspettavo che stavo cadendo invece è
stata salvata
non devi saltare delre e riproviamo è
davvero difficile farla scendere su
quello di sotto casa
forse ci siamo quasi forse ci siamo
quasi bravissima wow i tuoi preferiti
come faccio ad abbassarmi mi posso
abbassare
non penso a ok dovevo solo piano quanto
fatto ma come un fatto non morire ancora
caputo c'è quasi riuscita a portar ci
credo saltando così in continuazione
c'è un trucco perché io salto così in
continuazione poi però nell'ultimo ti
devi fermare bravissimo ha funzionato
non ci credo che è finito no no no no ma
penso accede non mi dire no no non è
ritornata indietro plastino sbagliato
anche il mio rivale salvo dice però che
devo scendere da questa montagna che
cos'è quali attori è accaduto qualcosa a
1 su una scuola bus
sì perché arrivato busti posso negarlo
no meglio di no
posso dire con cosa scendere
peccato questo sarebbe piaciuto ma non
riesco a guidarla molto bene mi sono
incazzato
forse è meglio è morta forse meglio se
senti a piedi ma no no no ora dico pure
pronti franti paura che facendo avanti
non dirò niente purtroppo ha rotto pure
l'idea già che ci sei non vuoi rompere
anche a cani ma anche troppo bene adesso
sulla spiaggia di ci sono le palme ecco
sono a roma piazza video una soletta e
l'uscita c'è scritto vincitori si
riusciva vincerà
non lo so che cos'è questo aiuto aiuto è
una trappola
secondo me sì ma dove
dove siamo finiti rocco la costa brava
andiamo a prendere il badge e vino e di
ceste troviamo il secret page ma sapete
che noi non riusciamo mai a trovarlo a
nuovi vedesi consigli del come si fa a
trovarlo
sta rompendo tutto bloccato verdetto non
andò bene queste remore
ma la supercar in a che voto gli dai
otto e mezzo tu con 9 dai tagli da te e
ora cliccate solo di questi gioca
seminari nelle nostre altre skip rumley
cade su quella che preferite
buona visione ciao